making money with and that is a goal
pursued by many developers to help
Android developers you launcher the
in-app billing API v3 in 2013 to make it
easier for the developer sheriffin ad
products and subscription within their
apps and now we are taking a new step to
simplify being further with the new play
building library this library includes
several convenience class as well as a
wrapper for the bidding service along
with you to focus on implementing the
logic specific to our app it not being
reliance on the Google Play Store app
which handles the communication between
your app and in Google's building
service fusion opinion features your app
must first request the cone Android
vending billing permission in your
Android manifest XML file choose the
library at the following dependents in
your build.gradle file by the tation
check on the plate being library page
for the latest version number try to
correct dependents in your app after you
set up we're good to go
and start using the play bidding library
to start sending being requests you must
establish a connection to the service on
Google Play using the following steps
first creating a building light instance
using the Builder class passing the
constructor act context and set a
reference to an instance soft purchase
applet listener you can implement this
interface in your activity when the user
finishes a purchase process Google Play
calls the own purchase updated method on
the listener that implements the
purchase a PD to list an interface where
you should handle the transaction result
second establish a connection to the
in-app billing service on Google Play
the setup process is asynchronous and
you must implement a billing client
state listener to receive a callback on
the setup is completed
overwrite the own billing services
connected callback method and implement
your own retry policy to hand lost
connections with in-app billing service
in the case the client loses connection
for example the plate being library
client may lose connection if the Play
Store service is repeating the
background you can check the full sample
code in our documentation with your app
connected to Google Play you can start
sending requests for in-app products
let's start by listing the products
available for purchase executing the
asynchronous method query ask you
details async to make a request using
query executes details async you have to
specify the purchase type in this case
ask you type in map and a list of
Product ID strings where each record is
a prote ID for purchasable item this
part IDs were defined by you when you
created the product list on the Google
Play console for my information about
creating a product list see
administering net billing you must also
specify a listener which implements the
SQ details response listener interface
that overwrite the own ask you details
response method to handle the method
result call the response code method on
the skill details result object to check
for the response code response code
should be billing response okay if the
requested finish successfully to view
all the possible response code from
Google Play CPE be liable reference to
retrieve the list of ask you details
objects call the get ask you details
list method from the ask you details
result you can call a variety of methods
on SQ details objects to be relevant
information about each item such at its
price or description of course being
able to just this product doesn't lead
to profit to start that purchase request
from your app call the launch bidding
full method on the play beating every
client from the UI thread pass a
reference to the billing flow params
object that contains the relevant data
to complete the purchase such as a price
ID of an item and the purchase type in
this case SQ type in map to get an
instance of billing flow params
use the billing for parents builder
class calling the launch building flow
methods place a google pay you are
purchase the screen we will pay provided
interface for users to enter their
payment method as mentioned earlier when
the user finishes the process who will
play calls the own purchase update
method on the listener that implements
the purchase of the detail decent
interface in this method each purchase
will be a item a list as you can see
here when you receive the purchase
response from google play perform
securitisation air on backhand don't
trust the client since an Android app
could be the compilot linear security
checks replace the disturbs to retrieve
the history of user purchase called the
quality purchase method on the play
building library client the Google Play
service returns the purchase made by the
user account associated with the app
install if the request successful the
play being leveraged store is a query
result in a list of for personal objects
to retrieve the list call the gauge
purchase list method on the purchase
result object the purchase object has
methods through the relevant information
about the item such as a purchase date
our time google play prevents the user
from owning more than one copy of an
item by product ID the item must be
consumed before it can be purchased
again your app controls how items are
consumed to consume items you first
implement an instance of consumer
response listener to handle the
consumption result then you call the
consume async method on the play being
library client passing the identifying
purchase token string value in the
response code in unconstraint finished
from the are consumed response listener
is billing ok it's time to call method
that implements the logic in your app
trippity the players inventory or
release glad to be used
another great feature covered by
playability is subscriptions but before
launching the bidding flow for
subscriptions called the east featured
supported method on the paid building
library client should check the device
supports descriptions with the type s
feature type
subscriptions per changing or renewing a
subscription see March launched in the
purchase role for product you just set
the prototype to skew types oops and the
product ID of the subscription before
you call launching billing phone if the
user is changing the subscription option
you must also pass the product IDs for
the subscription items you are replacing
in the beating flow parents object using
the add or the SKU method you can create
an instance of bidding flow parents
using the billing for parents builder
class just as in purchase Google Play
returns the result of the operation
using all
purchase update call back this library
is designed and maintained by our
engineers and we make plans to keep it
up to date with the latest in a B&E API
and Google Play app if you want to see
details of how to use the play bean
library including support for Android
wear and Android TV check the refreshed
version of the trivial drive sample we
look forward to hear your feedback about
this new library thanks for watching bye
[Music]